here is the chance thank you all for
joining us at Bloomberg from the way we
communicate and collaborate to the way
we buy and sell goods and services
digital technology has transformed
nearly every aspect of our economic
lives
how do I know that because I too just
like Matt asked chat gbt to craft the
opening lines of this speech and who
needs politicians when you've got AI
like other countries
the UK has been dealing with economic
headwinds caused by a decade of Black
Swan events a financial crisis a
pandemic and then an international
energy crisis
and my party understands better than
others the importance of low taxes in
creating incentives and fostering the
animal spirits that spur economic growth
but another conservative Insight is that
risk taking by individuals and
businesses
can only happen when governments provide
economic and financial stability
so the best tax cut right now is a cut
in inflation
and a plan I set out in the Autumn
statement tackles that root cause of
instability in the British economy
the Prime Minister talked about halving
inflation as one of his five key
priorities
and doing so is the only sustainable way
to restore industrial Harmony
but today I want to talk about his
second priority to grow the economy and
just in case you weren't completely sure
that I've helpfully put it up on a
screen behind me
we want to be one of the most prosperous
countries in Europe
and today I'm going to outline the four
pillars of our plan to get there
just as our plan to halve inflation will
require patience and discipline
so too will our plan for prosperity and
growth
but it's also going to need something
else which is in rather short supply
optimism that we can get there
just this month columnists from both
left and right
have talked about an existential crisis
written teetering on the edge
and that all we can hope for is that
things don't get worse
I welcome the debate
but chancellors too are allowed their
say
and I say simply this declinism about
Britain is just wrong it's always been
wrong in the past
and it's wrong today
some of the Gloom is based on statistics
that don't reflect the whole picture
like every G7 country our growth was
slower in the years after the financial
crisis than before it
but since 2010 the UK has grown faster
than France Japan and Italy not at the
bottom but right in the middle of the
pack
since the brexit referendum we've grown
at about the same rate as Germany
yes we've not returned to pre-pandemic
employment or output levels but an
economy that contracted 20 percent
in a pandemic
still has nearly the lowest unemployment
for half a century
and whilst our public sector continues
to recover more slowly than we would
like from the pandemic strengthening the
case for reform
our private sector has grown seven and a
half percent in the last year
yes inflation has risen
but it's still lower than in 14 EU
countries with interest rates Rising
more slowly than in the US or Canada and
yes we have to improve our productivity
but output our work is now higher than
pre-pandemic and last week a survey of
Business Leaders by PWC said the UK was
the third most attractive country for
CEOs expanding their businesses
economists and journalists know you can
spend a long time arguing the toss on
statistics
but the strongest grounds for optimism
comes not from debating this or that way
of analyzing data
but from what we've been hearing about
this morning our long-term prospects
because when it comes to the Innovation
industries that will shape and Define
this century
the UK is powerfully positioned to play
a leading role
let's just look at some of them
in digital technology as we heard from
Michelle
we have become only the third economy in
the world with a trillion dollar sector
we've created more unicorns than France
and Germany combined with eight UK
cities now home to two or more unicorns
the London Oxford Cambridge triangle has
the largest number of tech businesses in
the world outside San Francisco and New
York
PWC say that UK GDP will be up to 10
percent higher in 2030
because of AI alone
fintech attracted more funding last year
than anywhere in the world outside the
U.S
or Life Sciences where we also have the
largest sector in Europe and a brilliant
Advocate with our superb science
Minister George Freeman
we produced one of the world's first
coveted vaccines
estimated to have saved more than 6
million lives worldwide we identified
the treatment most widely used to save
lives in hospitals saving more than a
million lives across the globe
we're behind only the U.S and China
in terms of high quality life science
papers published and every one of the
world's top 25 biopharmaceutical firms
has operations in the UK
another big growth area is our green and
clean energy sector
the UK is a world leader here with the
largest offshore wind farm in the world
last year we were able to generate an
incredible 40 percent of our electricity
from Renewables and on one day a rather
windy December the 30th we actually got
60 percent of our electricity from
Renewables mainly wind
McKinsey estimate that the global market
opportunity for UK green Industries
could be worth more than a trillion
pounds between now and 2030.
and we're proceeding with a new plant at
sizewell C led by our brilliant business
secretary who also spoke very wisely and
surprisingly classically earlier on
um and I could also talk about our
creative Industries which employ over 2
million people who grew at twice the
rate of the UK economy in the last
decade and have made the UK the world's
largest exporter of unscripted TV
formats helped give us a top three spot
in the Portland soft power index
or our Advanced manufacturing sector key
to exports where we produce around half
the world's large civil aircraft wings
and its biggest Aero engines as well as
around half the world's Formula One
Grand Prix cars
and the golden thread
running through the industries where
Britain does best
is innovation
amongst the world's largest economies
the global Innovation index ranks us
fourth globally
those Innovation Industries now account
for around a quarter of our output
they've been responsible for nearly all
our productivity growth since 1997.
and they're also the reason that all of
you are here in the audience we've got
leaders from meta Microsoft Amazon Apple
and Google the world's largest tech
companies all with major operations in
the UK we've got monzo and revolut
Ely shining examples from our
world-beating fintech sector
we have Founders and CEOs from one of
some of our most exciting UK technology
companies like proximi and matilon
you are vital for Britain's economic
future
Britain is vital for your future too
so I want to ask all of you
to help our country achieve something
that is both ambitious and strategic
I want to ask you to help turn the UK
into the world's next Silicon Valley
what do I mean by that
if anyone is thinking of starting or
investing in an innovation or
technology-centered business
I want them to do it here
I want the world's Tech entrepreneurs
life science innovators and green tech
companies to come to the UK because it
offers the best possible place to make
their Visions happen and if you do
we will put At Your Service not just
British ingenuity
but British universities to fuel your
Innovation Britain's financial sector to
fund it and a British government that
will back you to the hilt
our universities are ranked second
globally for their quality and include
three of the world's top ten
in order to support the groundbreaking
work they do in so many new Fields the
government has protected our 20 billion
pound research budget now at the highest
level in history
and as you look for funding to expand
we offer one of the world's top two
Financial hubs and the world's largest
net exporter of financial services
the capability of the city of London
combined with the research strengths of
our universities makes our aspiration to
be a technology superpower not just
ambitious but achievable
and today I'm here to say the government
is determined to make it happen
but like any business embracing new
opportunities
we should also be straight about our
weaknesses
cultural issues like poor productivity
skills gaps low business investment
and the over concentration of wealth in
the Southeast have led to uneven and
lower growth
real incomes haven't risen by as much as
they could as a result confidence in the
future though starts with honesty about
the present
so we want to be one of the most
prosperous countries in Europe
and today I want to set out our plan to
address those issues
that plan our plan for growth
is necessitated energized
and made possible by brexit
the desire to move to a high wage high
skill economy is one that's shared on
all sides of that debate
and we need to make brexit a catalyst
for the Bold choices that will take
advantage of the nimbleness and
flexibilities that it makes possible
so this is a plan for growth it's not a
series of measures or announcements
which we'll have to wait I'm afraid for
budgets and Autumn statements in the
years ahead
plan is a framework against which
individual policies will be assessed and
taken forward
and I set out
that plan those priorities
under four pillars
they build on the people Capital ideas
themes set out by the Prime Minister
last year in his maze lecture
and as such are the pillars essential
for any modern innovation-led economy
for ease of memory
the four pillars all happen to start
with the letter e
the four e's of economic growth and
prosperity
and they are Enterprise
education employment and everywhere
so let's start with the first e which is
enterprise
if we're to be Europe's most prosperous
economy
we need to have quite simply its most
dynamic and productive companies
now there's a wide range of literature
citing the importance of
Entrepreneurship on business dynamism
whereby more productive firms enter and
grow and less productive firms shrink
but I don't just believe the theory I've
put it into practice I set up and ran my
own business for 14 years
it was one of the best decisions I ever
made
and I actually owe it to Margaret
Thatcher and Nigel Lawson
Because by the time I got to University
and was thinking about my career options
they had changed attitudes towards
entrepreneurship
had they not I would probably have ended
up in the city or the Civil Service
instead I took a different route to end
up in the treasury less the fast stream
more the long way around but like
thousands of others setting up on their
own
I learned to take calculated risks
to live with uncertainty
and to work through failures of which
there were many
every big business was a startup once
and we won't build the world's next
Silicon Valley unless we nurture
battalions of dynamic new Challenger
businesses
today we are already ranked by the World
Bank as one of the best places to do
business amongst large European nations
second only to America in the G7
and the result of that pro-business
climate is that since 2010 we've created
more than a million new businesses in
this country
but the question I want to ask is how
are we going to generate the next
million
firstly
we need lower taxes
in Britain even after recent tax Rises
we have one of the lowest levels of
business tax as a proportion of GDP
amongst major countries
but we should be explicit high taxes
directly affect the incentives which
determine Decisions by entrepreneurs
investors or larger companies about
whether to pursue their Ambitions in
Britain
with volatile markets and high inflation
sound money must come first
but our ambition should be to have
nothing less than the most competitive
tax regime of any major country
that means restraint on spending
in case anyone is in any doubt about who
will actually deliver that restraint to
make a low tax economy possible I gently
point out that in the three weeks since
labor promised no big government
checkbook they've made 45 billion pounds
of unfunded spending commitments
but it isn't just about lower taxes
we also need a more positive attitude to
risk-taking
let's start with one of the most public
risks taken this year
Richard Branson his team in the UK space
agency deserve massive credit for
getting launcher one off the ground in
Cornwall the mission may not have
succeeded this time but what we learn
from it will make future success more
likely we should heed the words of
Thomas Edison who said I haven't failed
ten thousand times I've successfully
found 10 000 ways that will not work
Edison was American
and our attitude to risk in this country
can still be too cautious compared to
our U.S friends
but we are capable of smart risk-taking
in this country
started the pandemic we bought over 350
million doses of vaccine
without knowing if they would actually
work and we ended up with one of the
fastest most effective vaccine programs
in the world
we also need if we're going to deliver
those competitive Enterprises smarter
regulation
brexit's an opportunity not just to
change regulations but also to work with
our experienced effective and
independent Regulators to create an
economic environment which is more
Innovation friendly and more growth
focused
our chief Scientific Advisor Sir Patrick
Valance is currently reviewing how the
UK can better regulate emerging
Technologies in high growth sectors and
the government's identifying where to
reform the laws We inherited from the EU
in the digital space Sir Patrick is
working with a brilliant Matt Clifford
who we heard from earlier and our
amazing culture secretary Michelle
Donald both of whom
gave excellent speeches
before we conclude those findings we
want to hear from you and that's why
we've invited you this morning
and we'll repeat that process for green
Industries Life Sciences creative
Industries and advanced Manufacturing
finally when it comes to the E of
enterprise
there is a critical need for easier
access to Capital
particularly scale-ups
I'm supporting important changes to the
pensions regulatory charge cap I've used
the regulatory flexibility provided by
brexit to change the solvency to
regulations which will begin to be
implemented in the coming months
alongside other measures announced in
the Edinburgh reforms this could unlock
over a hundred billion pounds of
additional investment into the UK's most
productive growth industries
but there's much more to be done
and I want to harness the ideas and
expertise in this room to turn the E of
Enterprise into an Enterprise culture
built on low taxes reward for risk
access to Capital and smarter regulation
now the next e
is education
and this is an area where we have made
dramatic progress in recent years
thanks to the work of successive
conservative education ministers
the UK has risen nearly 10 places in the
global School league tables for maths
and reading since 2015 alone
our teachers and lecturers are some of
the very best in the world the Prime
Minister said having a good education
system is the best economic moral and
social policy any country can have
and that's why in the Autumn statement
we gave schools an extra 2.3 billion
pounds of funding
and why the Prime Minister recently
prioritize the teaching of maths until
18.
but there is much to improve
we don't do nearly as well for the 50 of
school leavers who don't go to
university as we do for the ones who do
we have around nine million adults with
low basic literacy or numeracy skills
over a hundred thousand people leaving
school every year unable to reach the
required standard in English and maths
and that matters
we are becoming an Adaptive economy in
which people are likely to have to train
for not one but several jobs in their
working lives
not having basic skills in reading and
maths makes that difficult sometimes
impossible
and equally important is what happens
Beyond School
we've made progress with t levels boot
camps and apprenticeships and so Michael
Barber is advising the government on
further improvements to the
implementation of our reform agenda
and we want to ensure our young people
have the skills that they would get in
Switzerland or Singapore
if we want to reduce dependence on
migration
and become a high skill economy the E of
Education will be essential
and that means ensuring opportunity is
as open to those who don't go to
university as to those who do
so
Silicon Valley Enterprises Finnish and
Singaporean education skills
let me now turn to the third e
which is employment
if companies can't employ the staff they
need
they can't grow
high employment levels have long been a
strength of our economic model
since 2010 we have seen a record
employment rate the lowest unemployment
in nearly 50 years and labor market
participation at an all-time high
partly thanks to the Coalition reforms
of a decade ago
we are at 76 percent employment levels
higher than Canada the U.S France or
Italy
but the pandemic has exposed weaknesses
in our model
total employment is nearly 300 000
people lower than pre-pandemic with
around one-fifth of working age adults
economically inactive
excluding students that amounts to 6.6
million people
an enormous and shocking waste of talent
and potential
of that 6.6 million people
around 1.4 million want to work
but a further 5 million don't
so it's time for a fundamental program
of reforms to support people with
long-term conditions or mental illness
to overcome the barriers that prejudice
the barriers and prejudices that prevent
them from working
we will never harness the full potential
of our country
unless we unlock it for each and every
one of our citizens
nor will we fix our productivity puzzle
unless everyone who can participate does
so to those who retired early after the
pandemic
or haven't find found the right role
after furlough I say Britain needs you
and we will look at the conditions
necessary to make work worth your while
that's why employment is such a vital
third e
Enterprise education employment
three key components for our long-term
prosperity
and I conclude with my final e
everywhere
that means ensuring the benefits of
Economic Development are felt not just
in London and the southeast but across
the whole of the UK
it is socially divisive if young people
feel the only way to make a decent
living is to head south
but it's also economically damaging
if our second cities were the productive
powerhouses we see in other major
countries
our GDP would be nearly five percent
higher making a second only to the
United States and Germany for GDP per
head
and that's why leveling up really
matters
and why last week it was so exciting to
see the progress being made
since February 2020
when the leveling up agenda really got
underway
seventy percent of new employed jobs
have been created outside London and the
south east
thanks to our Powerhouse regions we
remain one of the top 10 manufacturers
globally
and the same is starting to happen with
new Industries where the fintech in
Bristol gaming in Dundee clean energy in
t side
every region has seen pay grow faster
than London since 2010
which shows that our approach to
regional growth is working
but there's much more to do
and whilst government grants can play a
galvanizing role
they aren't the whole answer
we also need the connectivity that comes
from better infrastructure that's why in
the Autumn statement we protected key
projects like hs2 East-West Rail and
core Northern Powerhouse rail
digital connectivity matters as well
which is why under Michelle's leadership
full fiber Broadband is now available to
more than 40 percent of homes in the UK
last year four million more premises got
access with the biggest increases in
Scotland and Northern Ireland
but the E of everywhere
has to be about local wealth creation as
much as about local infrastructure
so this year we will announce investment
zones mini Canary wharfs supporting each
one of our growth industries each one
focused in high potential but
underperforming areas in line with our
mission to level up
they'll be focused on our research
strengths executed in partnership with
local government
with advantageous fiscal treatment to
attract new investment and we'll shortly
start a process to identify exactly
where they'll go
but spreading opportunity everywhere
needs local decision making alongside
local infrastructure and local
Enterprise
so we must also give Civic entrepreneurs
more ability to find and fund their own
Solutions without having to bang down a
White Hall door
shortly over 50 percent of the
population of England will be covered by
a Devolution deal and two-thirds covered
by a unitary Authority and that's a very
important part of that
but we need to move more decisively
towards fiscal devolution
so that fantastic local leaders like Ben
Houchin and Andy Street have the tools
they need to deliver for their
communities
so fores Enterprise education employment
everywhere
four is to unlock our national potential
to be one of Europe's most exciting most
Innovative and most prosperous economies
Bill Gates is supposed to have said
people overestimate what they can do in
one year and underestimate what they can
do in 10. when it comes to the British
economy we're certainly not going to
fall into that trap
we will remember the essential
foundation on which long-term Prosperity
depends namely the sound money that
comes from bringing down inflation
but right now starts our longer term
Journey
into growth and prosperity
world-beating Enterprises to make
Britain the world's next Silicon Valley
an education system where world-class
skills sit alongside world-class degrees
employment opportunities that tap into
the potential of every single person so
businesses can build the motivated teams
they need
and as Talent is spread everywhere
so we will make sure opportunities are
as well
yes there are many structural challenges
to address
and working through our four pillars we
will do just that
never forgetting though the combination
of bold Ingenuity and quiet confidence
that defines our national character
ladies and gentlemen being a technology
entrepreneur changed my life
being a technology superpower can change
our country's destiny
so let's make it happen thank you very
much
[Applause]
Chancellor thank you very much indeed
for that very substantive speech and a
very wide ranging exposition of some of
the opportunities and and a candid
assessment of some of the challenges
ahead the chances kindly agreed to take
some questions
um let me start if I may first you've
been in office since October been
through some significant moments
speeches
and changes
as you reflect on those first few months
but what are your sort of key takeaways
and how is it actually sort of impacted
your view on the overall economy now
that you're actually in post
well obviously I've learned a massive
amount in the the three months that I've
been doing the job but I let me say the
thing that hasn't changed from the days
that I set up my own business from
scratch back in the early 1990s I think
the most successful organizations are
ones that manage to combine tackling the
short-term problems doing all the
short-term firefighting that any
business any organization has to do
but never allowing that to deflect you
from a longer term vision and what I'm
trying to outline today is what that
longer term vision is and we know that
we have to deliver on these five
priorities they are the British people's
priorities and as far as the economy is
concerned getting inflation down is
absolutely Central and we won't stop at
anything to do that
but we also know that if we're going to
unlock our potential we have to do more
than that and by the way this is a
project that is not going to happen in
the next 18 months or the time span
before the next election
and really what I'm trying to say is
there is an incredible opportunity for
us as a country and we've just got to
grab it and there are things we can do
now as steps on that Journey even if
we're not going to get all the way there
but I would say that becoming the
world's next Silicon Valley
is the opportunity that if I'm able to
unlock with the brilliant team of
ministers you've heard from this morning
would be the thing that all of us are
most proud of
in 20 years time if it happens when
we're long gone from the front pages of
your newspapers and I think that's
something really you'll be pleased for
that for another reason but um you know
I think that's something we should all
be uh proud of and work hard for thank
you let's get into the questions that
chancellors currently agreed to take Joe
Hills from ITV
it's Joe here
uh yep there's a roving Mike who'll be
with you shortly thank you very much
it's Joel Hills from ITV News and
Chancellor you are a glass half full man
and quite right to you that's good to
see
um I want to pick up on the point you
made about decline ISM the evidence
clearly shows that as you point out many
countries have struggled with low growth
in the last decade also the evidence
also shows that the UK is towards the
back of the pack the evidence also shows
that since 2010 the typical household in
the UK has seen their living standards
full relative to countries we like to
compare ourselves to like France and
Germany your speech suggests you don't
acknowledge these things if you can't
see the problem Chancellor why would
voters believe that you can fix it
um Joe I think uh Joel sorry John sorry
no Joel Joel Joel uh let's uh let's get
that bit right at least um
I think you're completely wrong my
entire speech
is about how we deal with the
productivity Paradox which has been at
the heart of why we haven't seen that
growth in real incomes if we don't
invest in improvements in our education
system improvements in our skills if we
don't find Opportunities For The
millions of people who could work could
contribute to our economy but don't at
the moment we're not going to solve that
productivity Paradox and I don't think
it matters if you're on the left or on
the right
economists agree that is the central
issue if we address the four pillars
that I talk about we solve that we can
start to see a sustained growth in real
incomes and I would just say that if you
look at what's been happening I don't
accept that we're towards the back of
the pack compared to what other
countries are saying I think any uh
accurate
examination of the statistics says that
we've been affected in broadly the same
way as our peer countries the
differences are long-term opportunity
just last year becoming the world's
third trillion dollar Tech economy shows
that even in really difficult times we
can make incredible progress
Jim Pickard for natural times Mike for
Jim
quick question first have you ever paid
a penalty to hmrc and then the wider
question is Britain is under pressure
from the inflation reduction act in the
U.S with over 300 billion pounds of
subsidies for green Industries we now
have a backlash from the EU with
Brussels Gathering European countries to
do similar activities all we've heard so
far from ministers is complaints that
this is all terribly unfair I know you
don't want to talk about specific
measures in your budget but it's the
government thinking hard about how to do
something to help British green
businesses and industries which is
facing this major threat thank you
thank you Jim um on your first question
um I'm not going to talk about my
personal tax Affairs but I don't think
there's anything you'd find interesting
to write about if I can put it that way
um uh on your second question uh
yes we have some concerns about the
inflation reduction Act and the reason
is because we believe in free trade and
we believe that if we're going to get to
Net Zero which is extremely important we
will be more effective if we exploit the
competitive advantage that we have that
the United States have that Asian
countries that uh EU countries have we
will get there faster and
more cheaply than we would otherwise do
but are we worried about the long-term
future of our clean energy Industries
absolutely not we have uh the second
largest wind capacity in the world after
China the single largest wind farm we
are second only to Germany and Europe
for our
generation of electricity from
Renewables we have a massive amount of
investment and we have a massive queue
of people who would like to invest more
so we've got great opportunities I'm
sure we're going to sort out those
problems but you know we have said clean
energy
is one of our five key sectors and by
the way nuclear is a very important part
of that and despite the financial
constraints we prioritize size well to
show that we're going to make progress
in that area too
Paul Kelso Sky News
hi Chancellor Paul so Sky News you've
talked about honesty and you've talked
about brexit the reality of brexit for
many companies is delays red tape
additional costs they can't hire the
people they want to come to this country
and you can't stop the people you don't
want to come to this country would it
not be more honest to acknowledge that
brexit is failing on its own terms for
business and those terms need to be
readdressed no and I think if you look
at the facts our growth has been as I
said in the speech about the same as
Germany since the brexit referendum it's
a big change in our economic relations
with our closest neighbors and of course
that is going to need adaptation and of
course there is some short-term
disruption but I think it's completely
wrong to just focus on that without
looking at the opportunities for example
in the Autumn statement the solvency II
reforms which are only possible because
of regulatory flexibilities that we
wouldn't have had inside the EU mean
that we will unlock potentially over a
hundred billion pounds of investment
into the industries represented by
people in this room
so in the end brexit is a choice it's an
opportunity
and we can make it an incredible success
and I believe we will
Harry Cole from the Sun
good morning Johnson thank you I noticed
you didn't answer the specifics of Jim's
question there can I just push you on
that have you ever paid a tax penalty to
hmrc
um another theme the Prime Minister last
week said that tax cuts this year would
be idiotic do you agree with that
sentiment and if I may
um the transport secretary said last
year that hs2 phase one to Birmingham
was on time and on budget do you share
his optimism and will we be seeing you
open the treasury's famous famously
generous coffers to get up get it back
on track
um well I think it was a good way of
squeezing three questions into one Harry
um I'll repeat what I said to Jim that
I'm not going to talk about my personal
tax Affairs by the way I don't think
that
people at home are remotely interested
in personal tax Affairs they're
interested in these things and that's
what the government needs to be focusing
on hs2 was a specific priority for me in
the Autumn statement
um
I think that it is a source of national
embarrassment that the Japanese opened
their first high-speed line between
Tokyo and Osaka in 1964 two years before
I was born
and I am incredibly proud that under a
conservative government for the first
time we have shovels in the ground for
the London to Birmingham part of hs2 and
we are absolutely committed to showing
that we can deliver big important
infrastructure projects and by the way I
think they're extremely important for
leveling up and what was your third
question it was
tax cuts well look the
the biggest and quickest tax cut that
the Prime Minister and I can deliver for
families up and down the country is to
halve inflation that is eating away at
people's pay packets their spending
power it's pushing up the price of the
weekly shop and that is something we can
deliver quickly and will help everyone
we are committed as I may very clear to
a low tax economy and the difference
between conservatives and labor is that
we cut taxes when we can they never do
and that's because we recognize that a
low tax economy is one of the vital
ingredients for dynamism
entrepreneurialism to encourage people
to take risks and that's why we want to
do it when the time is right
Dr Nadine Haram from proximity I hope I
pronounced that correctly
to had Swan as an NHS surgeon but also
as a CEO and founder of a digital tech
company we see digital Health platforms
as a growing industry here in the UK and
obviously they offer an incredible
opportunity to provide solutions to some
of the key challenges we're facing on
the front line Workforce productivity
quality and safety for patient care what
role do you see them playing but more
importantly how will you support the
adoption translation and scale of these
Solutions across the NHS
well um
you know this is absolutely uh something
that I think has to be a huge priority
it was a big priority for me when I was
Health secretary I
um I I started the NHS app
um which became incredibly important
during the pandemic it's a huge priority
for Steve Barkley and what I would say
to you as a surgeon is that globally we
have a shortage of two million doctors
and we need to train more in the UK but
actually we are not going to to close
that Gap unless we embrace the
opportunities of Technology both to help
people work more efficiently
administratively so that surgeons don't
find that you know they have an empty
operating table because a patient hasn't
arrived but also because technology has
a huge role in prevention stopping
people needing to go to hospital in the
first place so I think there's a huge
opportunity I also think there's a huge
opportunity here in the UK because
despite the pressures that we see daily
in the NHS we happen to have the world's
best digital health record for 50
million people and if we can use that in
a way that allows information to be
shared allows research to happen we can
offer something that just can't be
offered by other countries
John Boop free from Amazon
good morning John bamfree from Amazon
Chancellor I welcome your remarks and
your compelling vision for the UK to
become the next Silicon Valley my
question is on your second pillar of
Education what more can government and
business do in partnership in the short
to medium term to create the right
skills environment that's required to
deliver this future growth
well thank you I mean it's a really
important question and um there's
obviously a lot that government can do
because we're responsible for the school
system
but when it comes to skills and
apprenticeships we can only do this in
partnership with business the
apprenticeship program has been an
extraordinary success the first visit I
did as Chancellor after the Autumn
statement was to see
hs2 being built at a junction outside
Birmingham and I spent time talking to
an apprentice who was incredibly proud
it was a four-year degree apprenticeship
she was doing that she was going to get
a degree at the end of it and she wasn't
going to have any tuition fee debt
either and it's really taking off
but I think there are
um things where businesses can help us
do more and one particular area I think
we would like to talk to you more about
is what we could do to encourage older
workers back into the workforce and also
to discourage them from retiring so more
Occupational Health Access to people who
have a mental health problem a back
problem when they are potentially
thinking of leaving the workforce I
think that's something where employers
can have a really big role also I think
when it comes to apprenticeships
there is a sense that apprenticeships
are for young people
but there are lots of people who
um are ready and willing to consider a
new career in their early 50s they're
expecting to work potentially for
another 20 years
and they might need a slightly different
type of apprenticeship a slightly
shorter type of apprenticeship and I
think that could be very good for you at
Amazon it could be good for for everyone
here so that's a dialogue that um with
Jillian Keegan we very much hope to
pursue
right we're going to wrap it up there
for a breakout and networking session
and then we're going to go to our
various round tables and panels
Chancellor thank you very much indeed
for that speech thank you for the
questions but thank you for everything
that you're doing in terms of engaging
the business really appreciate it thank
you thanks John thank you
thanks again that number on um you're
watching Sky News and you've been
listening there to the chancellor Jeremy
Hunter living a speech at the European
headquarters of Bloomberg not a great
deal of new news in that speech it has
to be said a lot of rehashing of
previous statements uh from the
chancellor of the ex-jacker it was
billed in advance as being an antidote
to decline ISM the chancellor trotting
out various statistics of economic
growth in the UK and comparing them
favorably with some of the UK's
International peers uh those uh
comparisons of course very very
carefully selected uh not really making
note of the fact that the UK has
underperformed uh all the rest of the G7
countries since the start of the
pandemic possibly the one interesting
new news line in it was uh his message
his call on the people who dropped out
of the labor force post pandemic
obviously the UK facing a big
productivity crisis and that has been
partly linked to the fact that a lot of
elderly or over 50s were workers highly
skilled workers have dropped out of the
labor force since the pandemic getting
on for 400 000 of them and have not
returned to the labor force Jeremy Hunt
saying there that he did want these
people to come back to the workforce but
there were no uh eye-catching policy
announcements in that speech on how he
might uh be able to entice these people
back into the labor force I guess we
will have to wait uh until such time as
uh he is able to give concrete details
on that and that will probably be in the
budget in early March I can give you
some reaction in the meantime uh to this
speech from Rachel Reeves of course she
is Labor's Shadow Chancellor and she has
said Britain has so much potential from
creating good new jobs in the industries
of the future to making our country the
best place to start and grow a business
Labor's proper plan for growth will
grasp those opportunities and make our
economy stronger to face up to the
challenges 13 years of Tory economic
failure have left living standards and
growth on the floor crashed our economy
and driven up mortgages and bills the
Tories have no plan for now and no plan
for the future it's time for a labor
government that will build a better
Britain so that's the reaction from
Rachel Reeves